you know I'm dying to write action so do
the rom-com and I will get you the
action in six weeks in Malaysia
Malaysian women I just want to write
something that shows love how it really
is you know not funny not romantic that
kind of sounds like a downer
love is about which is why when someone
says I love you I love you I love you I
love you my response has been I just
don't see myself ever feeling the same
way about you but then I met this girl
where's your social experiment hey know
what this seats made out of boyfriend
material sorry
I do this guy I know he's my boyfriend
oh you don't look too good oh gee have
the crab and I had the crab I think we
should just be friends that's allowed
right men and women can be friends
yeah squids and swallows you know how I
kill infatuation with a gun it's not
that hard man boy meets girl boy girl do
it happily ever after
I'm sorry can men really think that sex
is the answer to everything yes oh my
god you're falling for her playmates
were grandmother's and engaged to Anna
tell you I had a stealin you won't even
fight for the girl you look I don't want
you to marry this guy I love you there's
no one else I looked rom-coms aren't
true they're what we wish were true love
is confusing and it's terrifying and 99
times out of a hundred doesn't work but
if we have even the slightest chance
being that one
I'm willing to regret you for my life
are you
blood isn't a thinking thing it's a
feeling thing and this is what it felt
like for me